Okay, so now we're going
to start with a simple bar
plot of the MIT
international student data.
So first, let's load the
ggplot library, ggplot2,
and load the data frame.
So intl = read.csv("intl.csv").
Now, the structure of this
date frame is very simple.
There are two columns,
two variables.
The first one, the
region, and the second one
is the percentage of
international students
who came from that region.
So making a bar plot from
this data isn't too hard.
We start off with
a ggplot command,
of course, the first argument
being the data frame.
The aesthetic in this case is
to have Region on the x-axis,
and on the y-axis, to
have the percentage
of international students.
Now, the geometry
we're going to use
is, as you might
guess, bar, geom_bar.
We have to pass one
argument to this geom_bar,
and it's called
stat = "identity" .
I'm going to come back and
explain what that means.
I also want to label
my bars with the value,
so it's easy to read
in closer detail.
So I'm going to use
geom_text to do that.
And the aesthetic of
our text is simply
to have the value of a
label, the text of a label,
to be the value of
our percentages.
Let's look at that.
So yes, we have a
bar for each region.
The values are
between zero and one,
which looks kind of strange.
The labels are
actually lying over
the top of the columns,
which isn't very nice,
and the regions
aren't really ordered
in any way that's useful.
They're actually ordered
in alphabetical order,
but I think it would be much
more interesting to have them
in descending order.
So we're going to work on this.
First of all, though, what
is this stat = "identity"?
Well, it's pretty simple.
Geometry bar has multiple
modes of operation.
And stat = "identity" says,
use the value of the y variable
as is, which is what we want.
The height of the bar is
the value of the y variable.
Now, there are other
modes, including
one that counts
the number of rows
for each value of x,
and plots that instead.
So you can look at the
documentation for ggplot
to see the different
options and how they work.
But stat = "identity" is
what we want right now.
Now, the x-axis is out of order.
And the reason for this
is that ggplot defaults
to alphabetical
order for the x-axis.
What we need to do is make
Region an ordered factor
instead of an unordered factor.
We can do this with
the reorder command
and the transform command.
So let's write this out.
So we're going to transform
the international data frame.
And what we're going to
do is say, Region, it's
going to be a
reordering of itself,
based on decreasing
order of PercentOfIntl.
So if we look at the structure
of the data frame now,
we see there's something going
on in the Region column that
wasn't going before.
And that's that ordering.
So you might have also noticed
that I put a negative sign
in front of PercentOfIntl.
So that negative sign
means decreasing order.
If we had left that out,
it would have actually
ordered them in
increasing order.
So unknown or stateless
would have been first,
and Oceania would have
been second, and so on.
So that's one thing fixed.
Another thing we didn't
like was that the numbers
were between zero and one,
which looks a little bit messy.
So let's just simply multiply
all the values by 100.
So intl$PercentOfIntl =
intl$PercentOfIntl*100.
And now the other
things we have to fix,
like the text overlying and
the x-axis being all bunched up
like that, we're going to do
that in a new ggplot command.
So I'm going to break it
across multiple lines.
So we start up with the ggplot
command, as we did before,
actually identical to
what we had before.
So the aesthetic is
x-axis is the region,
and the y-axis is the percentage
of international students.
We break it into multiple lines,
so put the plus at the end
there, and press Shift Enter.
We're going to do a bar plot.
The stat =
"identity", as before.
And this time
though, we're going
to manually specify a fill.
I'm going to say "dark blue".
I quite like how that looks.
Now, we need the text,
and the aesthetic of that
is to have the label equal
the value of the column.
I'm going to add one
more thing to this.
I'm going to say vjust = -0.4.
And what this does is, it moves
the labels up a little bit
and off the top of the bars.
You can play with that.
So a positive value
will move it down,
and a negative value
will move it up.
Next, I'm going to
set the y-axis label
to be something a
bit more sensible--
so "Percent of
International Students".
And finally, I'd like
to fix up that x-axis.
So I want to get rid of the
word "Region," because it's
pretty obvious
these are regions.
And I also want to rotate the
text at a bit of an angle,
so you can read it all
on a plot like this.
That's done with
the theme command.
So the theming
we're going to do is
we're going to say the
axis title, the x-axis,
should be blank.
And the axis text on the
x-axis should be rotated,
so it's a text element
that's angle is 45.
And I'll move it sideways
just a little bit-- hjust = 1.
And there we go.
So we've got our labels
vjust-ed above the columns.
The bars themselves
are dark blue.
The numbers are now
between 0 and 100,
instead of zero and one.
We can read all the text labels.
And it's generally
a lot more readable
than the pie plot or our
original ggplot, at that.
Let's go back to the
slides now and talk
about what we've just done.